BFS, or breadth-first search,
is actually quite similar.
You're still visiting every edge and
marking off every node.
However, here you search
every edge of one node
before continuing on through the graph.
Again, we start with the first node and
mark it as seen,
then visit a node adjacent to it.
Once we mark that node,
we can add it to a queue.
Remember the difference between a queue
and a stack, like we used for DFS.
For a queue, we'll remove
the first element we put in it.
But for a stack, we remove
the most recently added element.
We go back to that first node and
visit everything adjacent to it, marking
each as seen and adding them to a queue.
When we've run out of edges,
we can just DQ a node from the queue and
use that as our next starting place.
We look at every node
adjacent to that one,
adding each one to the stack until
we've exhausted our options.
It's important to note that when we dequeue,
we're getting a node adjacent
to the one that we started with.
You can kind of envision a BFS as
creating a tree out of a graph.
The node that we started
with becomes the root,
the group of adjacent nodes is
the next level in the tree.
We need to continue adding
nodes one level at a time.
We finish off one level entirely
before moving on to the next.
And soon, we're done with our BFS.
The efficiency is still the number of
edges plus the number of vertices.
Again, we're visiting every edge and
vertex during our traversal.